while it's brought some much-needed life
back to the box office after a
disappointing summer Darren Aronofsky's
mother is the first casualty of the fall
after opening up to just 7.5 million
dollars the harder to find film stars
Jennifer Lawrence as the title character
wife to Javier Bardem him as a woman who
must deal with the increasing stress of
unwanted visitors entering her
once-peaceful home the film's vague
logline has been a topic of discussion
for months and the movie became even
more shrouded in mystery as confusing
trailers and TV spots at the airwaves
while mother was as hard to track as it
was to explain no one expected the film
to fall as far as it did let's take a
look at why mother has had trouble
finding an audience critical division
while the Rotten Tomatoes score on
mother isn't terrible critics were
certainly divided over how good or bad
mother is some reviewers hailed the film
for its visual brilliance while others
were left confused and frustrated
calling the pic pretentious and
nonsensical yeah I don't like that
people who I'm not a masochist but I
like I want a reaction from people
although Aronofsky's movies have been
widely respected even if his best works
are hard to watch twice mother's reviews
indicated it might be hard to watch even
once some accuse the writer director of
trying to mix in too much allegory and
extremism to the film to endure others
thought it was bleak just for the sake
of it and almost everyone agreed that a
screening of mother is an intense
bewildering and disturbing experience
moviegoers obviously enjoyed the light
thrill of seeing a movie like it's where
the scares are comparatively wholesome
but audiences obviously weren't as
interested in traveling down another of
Aronofsky's existential wormholes this
weekend and even those who did see it
were unimpressed it was the opening
night audience that earned the film the
rare distinction of an F rating on
cinema score mother isn't the first film
from a director to get the dreaded
rating Steven Soderbergh Solaris also
holds that distinction so some consider
it a badge of honor but it's still
surprising to see a film with the
director and actors of this caliber be
so thoroughly docked by audiences mixed
marketing given its difficult premise
almost no one goes into mother really
knowing what it's about in advance part
of the reason for that is reviewers have
had such a tough time explaining what
happen
even after seeing the movie and despite
google searches for explanations spiking
after the film's release the results for
such queries can be just as confusing as
the movie itself audiences may often
enjoy twisty films but the biggest
problem with mother seems to be that no
one can agree on the true meaning is
this all just a cautionary tale on
climate change is the title character
really just mother earth who is being
abused by Javier Bardem God devil hybrid
and all the terrible people that flocked
to him or is the parable about the
Bible's creation story what Jennifer
Lawrence's character as some kind of Eve
no one can be quite sure we are all
living on this one planet with one
mother who gave us life given that
Aronofsky's last movie Noah was based on
the Bible and did well in the
international box office it might have
seemed like a good idea to continue on
the theological train but the fact that
no one's quite sure what mother is
trying to represent makes it a very
difficult sell bait-and-switch while
Jennifer Lawrence's fans might have been
shocked by seeing her ditched that
defiant persona that has informed so
much of her career so far general
audiences were probably more surprised
by how little horror the movie contains
the original teasers her mother made the
film seem like a horror movie which is
what earned some serious interest prior
to release the film's trailer drew out
some of the film's biggest scares using
the sounds of a ticking clock to
underscore what seemed to be a
psychologically focused haunted house
movie even Aronofsky himself insisted it
was meant to be a scare it began very
much with wanting to return to the
horror genre and did in Black Swan
however in the end that genre
identification effort backfired because
mother is definitely not your usual
Halloween fare instead the movie delves
into the human psyche albeit with some
very freaky imagery while those who are
familiar with Aronofsky's prior work
might not have been surprised by that
those who were just following the cues
left in the film's marketing were likely
fairly turned off by what they saw stiff
competition choosing the perfect release
date can be all-important to a film
success and studios will occasionally
shift around titles based on what other
companies are scheduling this was the
case with mother which saw its planned
October release moved up a month to
avoid competing with happy deathday and
while that might have saved them from
going up against that movie's crowd it
did end up hitting the
pick against Stephen King's it which
defied all expectations at the box
office and continued to draw in
audiences for its second weekend rather
than trying out something they didn't
understand and no one seemed to like
moviegoers seemed to take the safe bet
for their weekend thrills by hitting up
it which had a lot more word-of-mouth
buzz wide release washout despite the
big stars attached mother is ultimately
in arthouse film and one that really
isn't designed for a wide audience
Paramount Pictures might have been
looking at the potential dollar signs
when putting mother out to more than
2,300 theaters right away but in
hindsight it might have fared better by
seeking a limited release first the
strategy to put a niche film on a
limited theatrical run first before
expanding was exactly what worked for
Aronofsky's Black Swan which was
similarly eerie and stirred up its fair
share of audience confusion at the end -
but because of the cultural must-see
moment that was produced by Natalie
Portman's performance in the pic enough
buzz justified getting it into more
theaters and the movie turned a nice
profit as a result perhaps a slower
rollout could have saved mother from
being lashed at by audiences right away
to kill any momentum the movie might
have earned by creating such a
conversation among critics thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]